いざ発表となると
何から話していいかわかんなくなりますね
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
ようやく発表されました動画のタイトルに
もある通り実は2年前から
私はじめしゃちょー
ゲームの
開発をしておりました
それをようやく今日
発表することができました
ようやくですよようやく発表まで来ました
よえー長かった
長かったあのいろいろ聞きたいこと何なの
それとか質問もたくさんあると思うんです
けども1個ずつ細かく
細かくというかまわかりやすく話していき
たいと思いますまず
ゲームのタイトルスマホゲームですこちら
神流し島
こちら動画のタイトルあ動画じゃねえや
ゲームだゲーム実はセカンドキャリーを
築いてゲームプロデューサーになると思っ
てます
嘘です嘘ですゲームプロデューサーなんで
なる気はないですただなんでこのゲーム
作ろうかってなった時にはじめしゃちょー
僕っていう人間ゲームで成り立ってて
カードゲームだったりスマホゲーム
もちろん
据え置きのスイッチとかプレステ5とか
いろんなゲームで遊んで育ってきて
やっぱり
ゲームというものが欠かせない人間でして
そんなゲーム大好きアニメ大好きオタク
みたいな僕があ見た目に反して一緒に
ゲームを作らないかっていうお話お誘いを
2年前2020年の9月頃にお話を
いただきましてじゃあやってみましょうと
いうことでどういうゲームを作るかとか
これはこうした方がいいとかそういう
話し合いをかけて2年以上の月日が経ち
ようやく本日
髪流してしまうこちらのゲームの
発表をさせていただくことができました
どういうゲームかと言いますととりあえず
はまずPV見ていただきたいと思います
緊張しますねどうぞ
今日はいつも通り学校に行って
授業を受けてお昼休みにほむらちゃんと
アニメの話を少しして
放課後に
記者さんが取材に来るから
先生に付き添ってもらった
それから
[音楽]
ね
思い出せない
[音楽]
[拍手]
ここはどうしてこんなことになってしまっ
たの
状況を整理しましょう
これで十分だ
君の場所ねありえない
そんな私は
救えなかったのに
上永谷島
輪廻の巫女
見てもらったらわかる通り
怖いですちょっと怖いゲームになっており
ますそもそもゲームを作ろうって話になっ
た時本当にゼロからねもうどんなゲームを
作ってもいいみたいなはじめしゃちょー逆
にどういうゲーム作りたいですかってこう
言われてお話してる時に俺何好きなんだろ
うって真剣に考えた時
ホラーゲーム好きなんですよ
ホラーというかサスペンスというか
ちょっと奇妙というかコーラというより
不気味何かよくわかんないものとかなんか
アニメで言うと僕ひぐらしのなく頃にとか
めっちゃ好きだったんですよああいう
ちょっと
読めない何か読めない謎の
恐怖心のある何かと戦う的なものがすごい
好きでそしてもう1つの要素
美少女です私美少女大好きなんですえー
これもちょっとひぐらしのなく頃にの影響
が大きいのかなその悲劇のヒロンってわけ
じゃないですけどもなんか美少女がそう
いう境遇に立たされてとかなんか恋愛
ゲームとか好きなわけじゃないんですけど
もその美少女が戦ったりとか可愛い女の子
のアニメとかは結構好きなのでそこの
掛け合わせで何か面白いゲームができない
かなということで私も参加させていただい
て神流してしまうの制作になったという
わけでございますあのもちろん僕が全部
作ってるわけじゃないですよなんなら
ちょっとかもしれないです関わってる部分
ゲームの開発とかシステムエンジニアとか
そういうの僕全くわかんないし
プログラミングとかどうすればゲームが
売れるのかとかゲームの仕組みとか作り方
とか売れ方とかも全くわかんないので純粋
に僕が作ってみたいゲームがこれは僕が
好きなゲーム純粋にそういうの言葉にして
話し合いして実現したゲームになってます
そうでもないわ結構口出しはしました主人
公の亜麻仁みこちゃんというキャラもいる
んですけどもこの子にたどり着くまでを
かなり口出ししてここがこうだここは違う
もう髪の毛とかもそうすごいこだわって他
のキャラもたくさんいるんですけども
相当こだわってゲーム専務ですねもう
いろんな案を出しましたどういうゲームが
いいのかもう色んなゲームがある中でどう
すれば恐怖心を感じながら楽しめるのかと
か
[音楽]
喋りすぎても良くないな俺ばかりは喋り
すぎても良くないですぜひ実際に噛み流し
てしまう皆さんに遊んでもらいたいと思っ
てますとりあえず何が言いたいかというと
めちゃくちゃこだわってますってところ
ですねキャラデザインもそうです
モーションデザイン
女の子のアルク仕草とかって人と違うだけ
でめっちゃ可愛かったら超ダサくなったり
するんですよそういう歩き方だったり動き
とかモーション
相当口出しさせていただきましたあと
マップデザインですね
結構自由に動けるゲームになってます
上中島という島を結構自由に歩けるように
なっててそこの雰囲気作りというかここも
ほぼ僕めちゃくちゃママにいろんなこと
言わせていただきましたもうね
俺は
怖いとか気持ち悪いとか
ホラーというかなんかもう人間の恐怖心が
煽られる存在にすごい興味があって
僕ほら
嫌いなんですよ映画とかのホラーも
嫌いじゃないけど見ちゃうみたいな怖い
もの好きなんですよねきっとなんか
ひねくれてるんですよそういう思考みたい
な部分がきっとでもやっぱり奇妙なものと
かこのように存在しないものとかこんな中
には行きたくないとかここはどうなってる
んだ謎が
多すぎてわからないとか
ミステリアスな部分ってすごい人の興味を
引くものであるなと思いましてマップの
デザインとかこういう島にしたいそういう
ことはかなり口出しさせていただきました
逆にその美少女のセンスとか趣味っていう
のは本当にいろんな人に遊んでもらいたい
ので僕一人のこだわりはバンバン言ってて
も仕方ないと思っていろんな方とお話しし
あったり意見を出しちゃったりあそれが
いいですねっていうのを聞いたりして
いろんなキャラを登場させることになり
ましたま簡単に言うと逃げろ
島で逃げろというゲームになってます
まあまあまあリリースはまだしないので
細かい話はぜひ遊んでみてからにして
くださいただ徐々に情報出たりとかサブ
チャンネルでひょっとしたら先行して遊ん
だりすることはあると思いますのでぜひ
新しく情報を楽しみにしていてください
ただ本当に僕が
怖くて気持ち悪くて恐怖を覚えるそして
なぜこうなったのかかなり気になる世界観
にはなっています
ぜひそんな噛み流してしまうというゲーム
楽しみにしててくださいいやー
はじめしゃちょーゲームって言ったら
いろんなゲーム今まで作ってきたんですよ
ねはじめしゃちょーのもやしを抜くゲーム
とか
僕とトミックさんがモチーフになってた
ゲームとかいろんなアプリありますけども
今回はそういうなんかはじめしゃちょー
売りにしてるゲームじゃなくて
本当に僕抜きで
ゲームとして面白いゲームを作りたい噛み
ながら島に僕が思ってたって出るという
より裏で結構そのはじめ社長というより
1人のそういうなんかゲームを作る人とし
て
裏でいさせていただいてますもちろん今
からどんどん大詰めでリに向けていろいろ
改良していくわけなんですけれども
本当にクオリティの高いものができると
思ってますゲームシステムとかゲーム性に
関してはもう僕がプロじゃなくどこできる
部分じゃないので
歩き方とかジャンプのその空間の落下速度
とかヌルヌルすぎると嫌だとかこうしたら
もっと人間味が出るんじゃないかとか
ピンチになった時の音楽BGM効果音これ
だとダメだとか
演出的な部分もかなり言わせてもらいまし
た1ゲーム好きとしてもちろん僕1人の
意見じゃないんですけどもたくさんの人で
頑張って
髪長島というやばいゲームを
作りたいと思っているのでぜひ皆さん
遊んでみてください今日ですね記者会見と
いうか発表会がありましてそちら下の
リンクから見れるようになっておりますの
でぜひそちらも
チェックしてみてください
声優さんだったりコスプレイヤーの方が
登場してかなり盛り上がっていました
本当に大変だなって思った
2年間でしたね僕が全部作ったわけじゃ
ないんですけども
考えることが
結構
多いなってゼロから携わってみて思いまし
たほんと僕もYouTubeの活動がある
ので僕が携われた部分ってかなり少ない
ですけどもそれでもここまでたどり着くの
に2年以上かかったなって思うと
いや
すごいなって思いますはじめしゃちょー
裏でそんなことしてたんです実はようやく
発表できてよかったただ大事だなここから
だとは思うのでとりあえずあんまりベル
から喋ることもないんですよゲームに対し
て
謎が多いゲームなのでぜひ皆さん
髪長洲島の秘密を
解き明かしてみてください以上ですじゃあ
な
[拍手]
[音楽]